JTC had a vision to create a business
it's a series of green corridors
bisecting apart and they all lead
towards a central area which is actually
a lowland freshwater
one of the great values gyorko garden is
really preserves what's important that
was unique amidst that space special so
there is more than just a place for work
it's a place where you play and relax
one interesting element is the creation
of our green corridors for animals to
move to us the swamp area we had to
deepen this corridor right and we had to
treat the slopes of heavy planting in
order to create a sense of privacy and
security so that the animals would feel
comfortable to move true we have to
create a new lowland in freshwater swamp
well Durham area which is this part is
located used to be also forests it's all
gone so we have to bring a little bit of
that back we have to work with
ecologists to create this creating the
right environment conditions in order to
allow the trees to flourish so that was
quite challenging the challenges these
days are pretty complex so we typically
have multidisciplinary teams working
together understand we typically have
many architects architects ecologist
while life consultants engineers all
working together they start to realize
this vision the person design what is
important because it really highlights a
contribution designers and makes users
aware of the importance of design and
how it really enriches the daily life I
would advise all emerging designers to
stay passionate and never stop learning
this is jeroni co garden design of the
earth
you